so schauts aus liebe zuschauer noch zwei
mal schlafen dann ist es tatsächlich
eine ganze generation deutschen beginnt
ein neues zeitalter nämlich ein neuer
bundeskanzler mitnimmt von der
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel die rote
quasi geht in rente ich finde in der
vorweihnachtszeit und auch jetzt ist es
einfach mal zeit auch danke zu sagen ich
möchte sagen danke mutti mutti angela
nagel und warum weil sie bei mir
tatsächlich etwas ausgelöst hat das ist
so ein bisschen der sohn mutterkomplex
tatsächlich krisen krisen wir hatten so
viele thesen oliver kahn hat mal gesagt
druck druck druck für lauter druck spüre
ich gar kein druck krise krise krise vor
lauter käse ist die krise bei mir
oftmals gar nicht angekommen weil ich
immer wusste angela merkel steht für
mich für uns für das ganze land ein
flüchtlingskrise
ukraine krise euro-krise
griechenland-krise cola krise so viele
krisen und sie hat immer gemanagt und
eine sache davon auch nicht vergessen
ich kann sehr viel besser ins ausland
reisen mittlerweile als deutscher als
ich das noch vor 20 jahren konnte und
ich habe selber erlebt in südamerika war
ich vor 20 jahren nicht gern gesehen
jetzt bin ich sehr gerne und da hat
angela merkel einen großen beitrag
geleistet und für diesen sohn komplett
den sie bei mir aus dem lager ausgelöst
hat sage ich heute danke
kann ich kann das sehr gut
nachvollziehen ich bin ja quasi mit
angela merkel aufgewachsen für mich gab
es eigentlich mal nur angela merkel
gerhard schröder habe ich noch
mitbekommen aber meine schwester zb
sechs jahre jünger für sie gab es
wirklich nur angela merkel ich finde
dass sie auch viel für die frauen in
deutschland getan hat indem sie halt
nicht ich meine kamera harris wurde
gerade vize präsidentin hatte und mit
ihrer rede hier erklären gleich marvulli
allem ohne eine regung idee kam eine
halbe ist halt in ihrer rede gesagt ich
bin die erste aber ich werde nicht die
letzte sein und damit hat jedem gesagt
ich bin eine frau ich habe es als erster
geschafft das hat angela merkel nicht
getan und das finde ich toll hier dass
sie eigentlich eine feministin wider
willen ist und durch ihre unprätentiöse
und vor allem auch dadurch dass sie
nicht immer die frauen karte gespielt
hat eigentlich mehr für den feminismus
getan hat finde ich jetzt alle anderen
frauen und jetzt kommt die regen
hingegen redet von einigen eurer walter
haltung sehr ehrenwert dass jeder kann
seiner natürlich seine eigene haltung
angela merkel gegenüber haben ich habe
eine wechselvolle weil ich war lange
genug mit ihr zusammen nämlich volle 16
17 jahren sogar und das hat sich sehr
stark verändert ich mag mit dem begriff
mutti nicht umgehen weil ich kann mich
noch erinnern wie der zustande gekommen
ist der bahn nicht positiv gemeint der
kam nämlich aus der männerriege um die
frühe merkel herum und sie wollten sie
da ein bisschen ja ein bisschen der
lächerlichkeit preisgeben mutti ich habe
auch nichts mit dem multi begriff in der
politik verloren da bin ich viel zu
republikanisch für und danken tue ich
politikern schon mal gar nicht muss ich
sagen also ich finde umgekehrt das doch
dass politiker
ich finde dass politiker jeden grund
haben dem volk dankbar zu sein dass sie
gewählt haben das ist ja ein gas jedoch
dass sie nein nein das ist ein an das
verhältnis geht anders rum ich würde
gerne mal von angela merkel eine rede
hören wie sie dem volk dankt dass das
volk die so lange ertragen hat nämlich
16 jahre auf den letzten vier jahren
nichts mehr geht einfach darum dass alle
heute ertrag das volk wollte sie also
deswegen
werden wir wahrscheinlich ähnlich wie
ich auch mit angela merkel da als frau
an der spitze ich finde man eher auf die
kraft rausgezogen aber ihre ganz eigene
meinung in welchem lager wie wind
entsteht hier natürlich frei jetzt
tatsächlich muss man der stelle fragen
hat vermerke unser land geprägt aber
auch die welt geprägt das stück weit sie
hat durch krisen uns geführt wie
beispielsweise die finanzkrise spätere
wirtschaftskrise wie nahezu kein anderes
land und ist somit internationales die
krisenmanagerin eingegangen alle
entscheidungen letzten jahren waren aus
meiner sicht so vorteilhaft auch für
unser land oder auch für das miteinander
in unserem land und da gab's schon auch
hürden ich denke trotz allen dankes es
ist jetzt zeit für veränderung für
natürlich für endlich nicht mehr
aussetzen es war ja auch zum teil eine
politik des aussitzens des abwartens und
des verschiebens erst ist es zeit
wirklich veränderungen auf die strecke
zu bringen dinge anzupacken und zu lösen
und vor allem auch dabei einen neuen
polizisten politikstil einzuleiten das
ist die aufgabe auch der neuen regierung
und nicht zuletzt hat ja jetzt auch
gerade am heutigen tag die groko
den klassischen satz geprägt am
nikolaustag ist groko aus
ich würde mal sagen ja ich sage werden
auch nie sagen zur olaf scholz partie ja
auf den begriff mutti bei merkel völlig
unangebracht das ist nicht überall so
mann kannst du eigentlich auch ganz in
schwei ich will euch sagen meine profi
ist meine mutter ja aber jeder weiß auch
wie der begriff zu deuten ist das ist
eigentlich einfach nur eine dankbarkeit
die herz hat die hat auf uns aufgepasst
und zusatz und dass wir nicht aber man
kann doch nicht so blutig hat das sagen
wenn er was für einmal war fall ist hat
sie ja bei dieser glaube das wollen wir
beide sagen so ist es doch ein
sommertheater im so dass in anderen
fällen also da ist man nicht jeder
entscheidung ein verstand man sieht auch
dinge anders und rebelliert und sagt man
das ist aber quatsch was du machst
trotzdem und das ist das gefühl wenn es
hart auf hart kommt und ich selber sie
da nicht weiter so dann ist meine mami
dann genauso wieder eine großmutter da
ist und dieses gefühl kann doch ein
großteil der deutschen tatsächlich
nachempfinden ich finde es trotzdem auch
von sehr schwierig warum kann ich leuten
nicht danke sagen ich sehe habe ich eine
meinung nach habe ich doch die
werterhaltung und nicht rein ihren job
gut gemacht ja da muss ich auch nochmal
sagen sorry
in welcher kategorie der bundeskanzler
würdest du sie denn einordnen wenn wir
von top zu flocke wenn wir von den wenn
wir die frage ist ob wir bei amtsdauer
reden oder begebenheiten hat sich im
gegensatz zu uns ein paar kanzler mehr
mit ihr hat sie hat ganz zu anfang
ambitionen die hat sie aufgegeben weil
sie wegen der ambitionen haarscharf die
wahl verloren hat hat hat sicher
gewonnen aber es gibt war haarscharf sie
hat nie wieder schröders auch nicht
eingesehen hat nie wieder an der
schulter hatte dann schon projekt aber
sie hatte nie eins sondern sie ist dann
in die krise hinein geworfen worden da
konnten sie nichts führen und dann hat
sie sich dadurch gekämpft das
respektiere ich auch total aber sie hat
für dieses land und für ihre
regierungszeit niemals eine
sage jetzt nicht visionen wagner fassten
wieder leute auf niemals eine länger
tragen eine vorstellung gehabt sie hat
immer von heute auf morgen regiert dass
es mir zu wenig und wenn ich durch das
land fahren mit der bahn und bund und
ich komme dann eher eine gegend wo mein
handy nicht funktioniert dann bin ich
mutter nicht dankbar denn das wissen wir
seit 20 jahren das so ist und hat sich
nichts dran haben aber ist so vielleicht
auch mal genau der richtige weg dass man
also ich bin ja eher so ein typ der
immer das positive zieht und auch im
jetzt lebt ja vielleicht ist genau der
richtige weg nicht zu sagen so was
passiert denn eigentlich in fünf jahren
sondern ich lebe jetzt und entscheide
auch jetzt und nicht erst das ist schon
in ordnung ob es zu wenig also von einem
regierungschef der 16 jahre
werden
wo man halt die frage der der
langfristigen projekte aufzuwerfen von
dem habe ich sozusagen persönlich nicht
viel gehalten das war eindeutig helmut
kohl der hat die deutsche einheit
frühzeitig erkannt als chance und hat
sie gestaltet und er hat den euro
eingeführt und das ist viel runter
geputzt das ist das instrument das
europa zusammengehalten hat da hat man
immer gedacht das wird europa sprengen
hat es nicht es hat europa zusammen
gehalten also der hatte schon
historische vorstellung blühende
landschaften hat er dann auch noch ein
garten zum blühen gebracht doch wie
versprochen doch das sagen nicht alle
doch doch doch gemacht über irgendein
marktplatz ist alles neu geplättet ja
dass viel geld rein gefloppte stimmt
geld so dass die dass die sozialen
verhältnisse sind nicht in ordnung sind
die leute keine arbeit haben ist ein
anderes thema da ist auch nicht
unbedingt für verantwortlich gewesen da
war dann auch schnell weg aber
jedenfalls und willy brandt hat er auch
eine längerfristige vorstellung nämlich
entspannung mit dem osten also es gibt
schon kanzler die eine vorstellung hat
helmut schmidt nicht ist auch so einer
der regiert hat gut regiert hat aber
ohne länger tragende vorstellungen so
kohl war europapolitik deutschland
wiedervereinigung ganz eindeutig
adenauer war westbindung die hatten eine
vorstellung merkel hatte die nicht sie
hatte nicht mal eine vorstellung für die
landschaft aus der sie kommt nämlich
ostdeutschland die hat sie ehrlich
gesagt ziemlich vergessen ist ja zum
schluss wieder eingefangen haben ja auch
den den vorgemacht dass vielleicht auch
einfach 16 jahre vier amtszeiten zu lang
natürlich bin ich ihr gerne sie fragen
frau bauer wie finden sie es denn
eigentlich sollte man die vielleicht mal
verkürzen die amtszeit nur sagen es ist
nur noch erlaubt drei zu regieren wie
finden sie das als fdp na ja auf jeden
fall sollte man sie verkürzen wir sehen
sie einen anderen ländern weltweit die
durchaus damit mehr reformen mehr
veränderung auf dem weg bringen und wir
haben ja auch im bundestagswahlprogramm
gehabt dass wir das auf zehn jahre also
die bundestagswahl auf fünf jahre zu
verlängern die perioden und dann auf
zwei perioden im kanzleramt festzulegen
somit würde das land immer wieder
veränderungen erfahren und die erste
zeit ist natürlich auch eine
einarbeitungszeit in das neue amt in die
vorstellungen der anderen länder aber
auch sich dort vorzustellen und dann die
zweite periode auch zum wirken zu nutzen
division mit auf den weg zu bringen und
auf veränderung zu besonders
amerikanische und 7 in amerika in
vielerlei anderen staaten funktioniert
das genau so und das ist schon ein punkt
was uns zum nachdenken anregen muss ob
es wirklich sein muss 16 jahre oder ob
unser landes auch nicht verträgt
vielleicht auf zehn jahre zu gehen und
somit wirklich den reformstau den wir so
sehr verspüren dann einfach auch zu
erlösen und wir wollen ja auch einen
modernen staat wollen hier vorankommen
und das ist unglaublich wichtig und
glaub das wird auch unserem land ganz
gut oder zwei bemerkung zum einen wenn
ich das richtig sehe ist nach einer
koalitionsvereinbarung eine formulierung
drinnen die auf einer amtszeit
begrenzung hinausläuft sehe ich das
richtig korrekte erstens zweitens
das motto dieser neuen koalition mehr
fortschritt wagen knüpfte an willy
brandt mehr demokratie wagen das heißt
das klingt doch so als hätte diese
koalition war es vor was über den
augenblick hinausweist fortschritt ist
ein total verstaubter begriff gewesen
60er jahre hat die spd lange nicht mehr
angefasst jetzt wieder wieder raus
entstaubt wird wiederverwendet ist auch
notwendig und das klingt jedenfalls so
als hätte die neue koalition eine länger
tragende vorstellung ob das hält weiß
man nicht aber gut ist es also ich
glaube es ist immer wichtig und parteien
für wahlen antreten und auch dann im
lang veränderungen haben wollen dass sie
eine vision haben sondern natürlich wir
als fdp auch eine vision der modernen
staat seinen schlanken staat die bürger
fit zu machen die in dem video und zu
stärken in ihrer entscheidung ob das in
der weltbesten bildung ist ob das auch
damit dass sie auch finanziell
investieren können und voran leicht
gesagt die frauen stärken da frage ich
mich immer wenn die fdp über frauen
redet da muss ich schon sagen dann denke
ich mir immer okay dann fängt die fdp
mal in den eigenen reihen an da muss ich
sagen haben wir haben tolle frauen die
haben gerade beim letzten
bundesparteitag
unglaublich viele frauen noch davon
tatsächlich ist es aber auch um general
seiner greta alles land teil der liegt
sogar leider aktuell noch bisschen
darunter aber ich denke das kann sich
schon sehen lassen und wir werden ja
auch morgen als er wahrscheinlich einen
neuen fraktionsvorstand wählen wir
werden sehen wie sich das will die armut
johannes vogel vermutlich johannes vogel
er ist einfach einmal härter naja wer
ist ein prädestinierter
für vielfalt er hat in der parteireform
vieles gut gemacht und ich darf auch als
frauenpolitische sprecherin sehr eng mit
ihm zusammenarbeiten und es ist mir eine
freude und ich glaube dass wir da
durchaus neue akzente setzen werden und
es ist auch gut so also ich denke eine
gemeinsam über das liberale team in der
regierung müssen sich die bürgerinnen
fdp hatte in der vergangenen
legislaturperiode in der fraktion starke
frauen die aber nicht richtig zur in
erscheinung getreten sind weil der
fraktionsvorsitzende alles überwölbt hat
also es ist ja alles von linda gemacht
worden mehr oder weniger da gab es noch
kubicki daneben her das war der libero
der alles möglich
alle mögliche bälle ins in der welt und
vom feld runter geschlagen hat aber
immer interessant ja
und jetzt wird es vielleicht anders dass
die frauen in der fraktion habe
deutlicher zu sehen sein wie ich schon
gesagt wir haben zudem gute frauen ob
das bettina stark watzinger ist ob dies
die strack zimmermann ist ob das katja
suding war die jetzt auch neuen ist
perfekt nach zwölf jahre politik möchte
eine veränderung habe ich finde es auch
in ordnung in unserem land nicht jeder
so lange in der politik bleibt bis er
dann schon sehr
überraschend groß sind dass ich habe
danach gedacht wie schade dass frau so
den aus der politik gegangen ist hier
nach der sendung gesagt